so you you had some health issues but
you're doing well right I did uh I was
uh late right about this time last year
was in the hospital uh I went in for one
thing uh ended up having surgery for
five so it was buy one get one get four
free oh my that's scary no it was really
a very scary time Kelly it a very scary
time and Al is one who likes to look
forward not backward okay Optimist which
is great ever The Optimist but it was a
very very difficult time and we are so
blessed to have him in full form and
just great
but um I have to say too your um
granddaughter she kind of played a role
right yes yeah I found out uh while I
was in the hospital that my oldest girl
Courtney uh was expecting our first
grandchild and there she is little Sky
oh you can all go a I
know so special but I think more than
anything else I think just having no
knowing that she was coming along over
this last year exactly because it's been
a progression but you've just gotten
stronger and stronger and so here he is
so now when he drops his underwear and
his stuff on the floor or whatever and I
want to get upset with him I'm just like
you know they're there at least I could
have been dead oh my God he's going to
use it that's going to be a card this is
what you pray it's your fault you saved
me sorry you didn't want me to go
[Music]
[Applause]
anywhere thank you guys
y'all have a great night I'm going
home